Deep in the forest, in the river, lived a large crocodile.
He was a very selfish crocodile.
He didn't want any other creature to drink or bathe in the river.
He thought it was his river.
Every day, he shouted to the creatures of the forest,...
"Stay away from my river!
It's my river!
If you come in my river, I'll eat you all!"
So there were no fish, no tadpoles, no frogs, no crabs, no crayfish in the river.
All were afraid of the selfish crocodile.
The forest creatures kept away from the river as well.
Whenever they were thirsty,...
...they went for miles to drink in other rivers and streams.
Every day the crocodile lay on his great big back in the sun,...
...picking his big, sharp teeth with a stick.
But early one morning, the forest was awakened by a loud groaning sound.
Something was in terrible pain.
The creatures thought that it was an animal caught by the crocodile.
But as the sun came out brightly,...
...they saw that it was the crocodile who was in pain.
He was laying on his big back, holding his swollen jaw,...
...and he was crying real tears.